[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want
that's our intro put in the respect that
he has never watched one of these
instruments you know how I watch it hit
his face change so bad that's I watch it
how you do it oh wait a minute were you
a band geek no no I'm just about to be
me I'm just a musician all of a sudden
you're Pharrell because you're over
there with here what was the other guy's
name that was with never tunes the
random Asian do that around here I think
it was a challenging guy I think he
still producers he's balling a little
people to make the real money so people
behind the scene Pharrell killed him and
took his that's why finally eight
hundred years no don't put that out
there though that if you kill age and
you can steal their that so everyone's
gonna go out and look for a cynical
alright let's let's take that back no
clap do be your s damn it now we're
gonna have all these people trying to
kill his bail on you wanted to be
popular there you go I feel like
Pharrell legit was like some kind of
Egyptian Prince and it hasn't died like
he just doesn't he has a forgets that if
I can recharges and that's because when
you people have when you have money each
look young there's just there's things
that you do they got all those like
vitamin drips and b12 things and they
get us
true they you know you have money you
know like LeBron James he spends like a
million dollars a year on his body
why doesn't he invest some of that to
[ __ ] fix his hair some things can't
be fixed maybe that's that is the
millions of dollars
but he's fighting that war and that but
the war line is just keep going back and
forth it's just crazy how I get change I
get a makeup artist or just like print
just paint that [ __ ] like if girls can
do [ __ ] fake chi Chi's and like big
eyes like if we can create that illusion
I'm sure you can just do it for you know
what should get like the eyebrow like
tattoo yeah what if they get follicles
but they've done that what's it called
like tiger he was losing his hair he got
his a hair transplant or some [ __ ]
really there's nice and full flow to get
his ass hairs [ __ ] implanted can you
imagine that there's like the only ones
that are curly always see the eyes we
medical yeah like where they take hair
follicles from back here and hundra for
none days was known for doing that
really who the hell is that you just
like this famous Mexican singer oh dude
the prime I'm gonna get a toupee when
I'm old please just get it now please
thick rock wants to be funny
both these dudes here have like the
biggest [ __ ] hear it when you guys
dye your hair it's gonna go through the
[ __ ] casket what does it keep growing
while we die I heard of some [ __ ] like
that you know I don't you guys fans over
there that side of the tape what happens
I love the skin actually like you know
how we die it shrinks it looks like your
hair is growing
stay with your nails
look at that that's real facts dude like
my world better than though it's a
little more exciting
he keeps growing I look like mr. burns
no I'm gonna watch that [ __ ] max
Holloway [ __ ] Brian Ortega fight
though in San Diago you're gonna come
over I might could we're not going to
San Diego this weekend anymore he showed
me your conversation I just can't get
into fighting I just I can't just too
violent
I'm amazed by all of it it just looks
you know crazy like I don't like boxing
just because of Muhammad Ali just
because of like how he was in his later
life I just like man you feel sad too
much head trauma to my shell I like
football but again once you start
reading about all the stuff that's going
on you know but like every time you read
something it deters you from liking it
no more I know but when they give you
the facts you're just like I was on a
show I was on a show that was talking
they were talking about football he was
like denouncing football Adam ruins
everything
you know I got yeah I was on that show
was like and I was I got like a sort of
ESPN like you know commentator guy and
he was doing this thing about football
like how in the trenches they were they
have more trauma every single play than
any other well they still they're still
that's still muddy in terms of like if
that's true or not they're still
determining if that's like a the factor
but hey they know that they knew the job
was dangerous when they took it yeah but
you start all my body tea is unreal dude
I don't like but I don't like fighting
it or I just don't like how violent it
is it's just I don't know when I get
somebody like the MMA oh my god yeah but
somebody gets elbowed or something I'm
just like oh no stop I don't want it to
work
we're like a we're ten years away from
people dying in the ring and that's
being okay with that I like watching it
I don't like being a part yeah almost
we're giving towards Roman times were
they gonna be like we want to see
someone dope for that I must say make it
illegal yeah yeah oh you're sick I'm
saying like I don't like how they're
trying to legislate football the way
they are just because moms are out there
upset or whoever is upset about it's
like hey they signed up for this and you
know
carry their families is what we'd like
to see actual knowledge that this [ __ ]
does affect you cuz the way they it
seems like they kind of cover it up or
it's like it's not that bad it's not
that bad
no I think you're heavy but I think
really out there too dude yes I think
that football player the ex football
players like even basketball players you
see how they can't walk yeah what's the
hit like their 30s it's like we're 80
year old body have you ever heard one
interview of James Toney boxy boxing
like yo James times so what'd you think
about that ties in violence online yeah
um racket when the reports like yeah so
you didn't understand a damn where you
know upon the drunk-person he's hard to
understand yeah I did well you saw it
you saw that heavyweight fighter just
with the fat guy talk about Tyson Fury
and [ __ ] Deontay Wilder yeah should
not have been a draw but alright but the
fight after that that uh that guy
punched him in the gut and he ended that
fight and I felt it
oh the loser shot right shot but like
the guy the white you talked to white
guy was gonna win their first cuz he was
like bad he had him on the ropes you
were like wow wow that one hit the guy
gave up he said I gave this guy my best
and he hit me he hit me one time now my
guy I'm it's a liver shot it's like
getting kicked in the nuts yeah man that
guy was like you can't even control I
know he was just like oh [ __ ] I'm out
yeah yeah but I just I don't know I just
can't you know a lot for someone that
doesn't like watching it well I just
happened to be at a party that they did
the fight it's like you can't look away
yeah and that's I was like I was a with
it first of all I was like that guy
looks old as [ __ ] the other fight he had
like a great beer and I was like what is
this just like something out of like a
show or something it's like a WWF by
looking at fight unreal dude like the
amount of people that you see with ICT
damage it's it's odd because it's almost
like they can't tell what they sound
like
yeah and they expect us to understand
what they're saying to us you know it's
like dude you you got brain damage but
some of these fighters too they do it
for so long it's their identity and they
don't know what else to do and they're
not some of them - they're they can't
even teach boxing because they don't
even know how to teach
cuz they're just naturally good they're
just fighters so they just know how to
throw fists so there's the smart boxer
we'll do that and they'll become a
trainer and they'll develop like people
under them but that's also because they
love the sport and they know how to
teach well good for like some of these
things like what's his name Freddie
Roach no what's uh what's like Caesar or
what's-his-face he Oscar De La Hoya
Oscar De La Hoya and those kind of
people they came a promoter yeah I
became a promoter and and Floyd like
he's such a defensive fighter that he
was like gnarling I'm he does Nancy tea
at all he looks perfect he's like I'm
not gonna get uh I'm gonna save my
brains because he probably learned from
his dad and I mean you know there's
generations and they probably taught him
he can't read so tightly he does does he
teach he had it before he started boxing
do that sat next to him at a clipper
game because I got clipper tickets all
tight like there was a game like a
[ __ ] game and they were like Eric we
have an opening on the floor that's
awesome so at halftime my girlfriend and
I were got to go sit and it was sitting
next to him dude he's just full of
himself man like why he was just looking
at the sudden emerges this was being a
[ __ ] you know I mean I was like why
he really loves being who he is 100% you
know he loves that I think he had a bad
leg so that's just a bag full of money
it was it was on and I didn't even want
to like tell him to move like you know
because they brought us over and he had
his bag right there and I thought to
myself God is there a million dollars in
his bag oh this money he always walks on
that little back for a million dollars I
mean it's just great that's what he's
been robbed so many times what's it
called he doesn't take clothes with them
he is by Allen Iverson used to do that
too I heard he said that about himself
that's why you broke you said he would
travel and he would like buy clothes at
the mall and then to leave him in the
hotel well see Allen Iverson didn't make
plate Floyd Mayweather money so that was
it I mean he made good money at the time
but it's not fully made with the money
yes not 100 million dollars my friends
my friend told me his mom does that
because she owns a bunch of different
hotels and she it's very convenient
because she doesn't have to lug around a
ton of luggage everywhere and I was like
oh that makes a lot of sense not buying
no no she has assistants and they just
get her what yeah yes rich people stuff
you never thought of an assistant no and
I was one yeah and I was like oh that
makes sense for like convenience but if
they're not if they're just doing games
and just training it doesn't make sense
I can make sense for a businessperson
right like I don't know yeah matching
you like
are you buying socks and underwear too
and leaving that at a hotel
maybe I finished it just leave it in the
corner like a wasteful in the corner
when I went to when I first got close to
Bobby we were traveling in the Middle
East Bobby leaves his [ __ ] anywhere yeah
Bobby
he bought we were so bored you know just
in between shows and traveling to Bobby
bought an Xbox and then we would just
play fifa city no he didn't leave it
there but he actually should have
because it didn't work in the United
States
oh no oh hey buddy back but he was like
traveling around we were traveling
around with his xbox and it's just like
you know so I get I mean I get like if
you travel a lot yeah I travel a lot and
I have to always have my stupid bag I
always overpack you know then you have
to like you know you have your dirty
clothes you have to do all that how we
steal the plastic bag from the cleaners
plastic bag from the hotel right that's
what I put my dirty ones like TSA stops
you gotta open your bags all the time
and if it happens enough for them no I
[ __ ] I'm just gonna walk in like this
and they'll never be able to stop me
yeah that's just suspicious but know
that when people travel with no bags I
wish I could travel with no bags I
travel with my xbox I have this little
carrying case it's great with a monitor
in it
I try my best to never check-in luggage
yeah me too I they I have my [ __ ] lost
like twice and I was like I'm that
always say this I have not just jinx
myself but I've never lost my bag loser
loser [ __ ] loss of Dwight my friend lost
Z yeah it is you never found it I never
I got my back but I'm saying they didn't
lose it they just like to put it on the
wrong flight or they put it like you
that let's see you have to clarify
people think that like their bag just
disappears disappears
like they get misplaced or whatever that
they have like a store that you can go
and you can buy [ __ ] from people that
lost their luggage
yeah is it like a public auction they do
that too where it's like you can buy the
whole suitcase and you don't even know
what's in it so you can just buy the
suit price I want to do that I know
right you got the gamble that oh yeah is
that like storage wars for luggage I
love that show bag but I sure like the
luggage you just gotta look at the brand
of course right when is nice
first of all people that have fancy
luggage is the stupidest [ __ ] it's so
it's like buying a Ferrari to go
off-roading like it's so dumb people
have like Louis on luggage because you
see as soon as you like walk away
they're just like you know even when you
have a fragile sticker ownership we
traveled with our baby and they threw
the baby in there
wait you had you put you checked your
baby carrier and then I just saw the 3d
they were just like [ __ ] throwing it
on the container we had our stroller
they just grabbed the stroller were like
you're gonna put my child we need that
when we land
yeah the wheel [ __ ] breaks off and
they just thought well like what yeah
they don't care they don't give up oh
wow I would never spend I had a little
guy was running a little game hi sorry I
like I said I travel all the time so I
go to Macy's you buy a bag and what
people don't know is luggage has a
warranty like you there's like it for a
lot of luggage places give you a 10 year
warranty why the place you buy it from
will give you a year warranty like oh
yeah because this is what I would do a
year like the year would come and then I
would be like get a zipper don't work
and then I would take that bag back and
they get a new bag wow you are so Asian
that's the most Asian thing I've ever
heard of my life dude I travel a lot and
the bags get beat up even sense of what
the taxes if at all game on
for no reason somebody's coming hey what
the hell many but don't work no more
Oh die did I just give you [ __ ] three
free bags just with the fat valid acity
amazing so you get ten bags for the
price of wants to be the [ __ ] that every
[ __ ] like Vietnamese family did in
Sacramento they would Costco had this
great return deal for their TVs so app
is like a three year thing and so by the
time the three year comes up you could
just like return it and then get a new
TV like the new model year or yeah it
doesn't work but see they offer these
kinds of things because they know that
most people are gonna be like I want to
go to this [ __ ] house all people you
don't know [ __ ] it amazing Korean people
though yeah yeah if you're cheap [ __ ]
you like um hey it's I turn myself in do
you save like there's like a folder in
your home where you know you because
they have its computers now you know
they can look up your receipt I keep a
little file within like there but how do
you keep them like a note because I you
can do that with your mattress with your
luggage or the TV like how do you keep
track of all the stuff that I travel so
much I just know I see the bag it's beat
up I know I know I
you can feel it I got this in April you
have a connection with your bag
yeah yeah you know it's like ah this is
check that level of beat up this time
for me to turn this [ __ ] in you know
like my [ __ ] is [ __ ] up I need a new
one
how often are you on the road no see
that's because did you be surprised if
you really think about what your bag is
going through yeah obviously it's gonna
get beat up yeah like we most people
only travel like once in every five
years so they think like oh let me get
the bag out of the class [ __ ] stays you
know rolia yeah are you are you flying
out like every week or less it depends
because I was on a show last year so
it's like it was when you when I'm doing
that I don't travel as much cuz you have
to stay in LA staying in LA but when I
do travel it's like constant you know
it'll be like Wednesday come home go
back [ __ ] hate traveling man what
brand do you recommend cuz imma buy that
luggage
I don't ever actually what I'm saying is
I don't like that have a brand brand
that's indestructible no they're all
they're also based off of the warranty
yeah it's based on diversity
you get to one but it depends on the
store you get it from so I do suggest
going to a big department store yeah
because they usually have some kind of
thing there they'll have like a year
warranty based off their own at the
store that's not like about REI a lot of
their stuffs lifetime yeah then you just
you got to go back but people don't
think to do that that's why that's why I
can't stand rebates
that's the stupidest [ __ ] cuz they know
they be what they say well you get $100
rebate they know most people are not
gonna fill out the paper oh I feel that
[ __ ] out yeah money talking man I give
my money back you notice they don't do a
lot of rebates anymore because now it's
so simple
you'll be like no I don't know if it's
on the computer on your phone rebate
there they're like okay take rebates
away because it's too easy to do I'm
like this is too much worth [ __ ] say
this hundred dollars I go I do that
that's what it is the people just they
know people are gonna be like they know
me very like that
AMC like to me like the movie past all
the kind of stuff they know you're not
gonna go see three movies so they charge
you 19 dollars a month
it's a great deal I have it I travel a
lot so even if I just go to one movie
it's worth it yeah you know just one
movie and even in a month it's worth it
movie pass was great when it first came
out it like unlimited wasn't it they're
not making money
yeah that's they had to like didn't
anybody had restrictions that's why AMC
is like they're all there they're making
money cuz they're like us nineteen
dollars you can go three movies a week
any movie you want and you know but it's
that the people they know what I'm
saying is they know people aren't gonna
take advantage of it Clark case our soft
case I have a soft case the soft case
they get so dirty though I just bought
it that's another reason to once it
starts to get nasty I'm like I gotta
take this back I just make some [ __ ] up
yet a zipper doesn't work you know Apple
has like a great return policy but when
you at their Apple care like oh it's
like no questions asked yeah cuz my uh
my [ __ ] had like an issue with the
button and the guy was like no
technically still work so you can't
really I'll say okay well what if I just
walked outside and it broke those well
yeah so I walked outside and look [ __ ] I
went boom I shattered it I came back in
give me a new phone here's like okay
technically you have to cuz like what
the [ __ ] I was like just give me the
[ __ ] phone so I just walked outside I
smashed it outside and went back in here
it's broken I just need something to
type in like oh yeah
and they'll write whatever excuse to
heels like it'll wish I write as I tell
my one hiking and I fell on my pocket
cool you what that it how's that but
that's like but that's also depends on
your cell phone company within whatever
insurance I t-mobile's got a good plan
they got a good like that that jump
program were you just like well cuz you
can't really buy phones anymore from
those stores you have to do a payment
plan on it so they'll have like a return
so like what's it with my phone right
now after a year of paying I could
upgrade my phone exactly and just get a
new one but the thing is like these
phones are so expensive they're like
this like a laptop 2,000 bucks
I rather buy something to new thousand
bucks but if you want to get like the
512 gigabyte they're like it's $1,500
for four of these phones but I rather
buy something new than to deal with
customer service [ __ ] that I hate you
know customer service I can't stand
being on the phone with them for even
two minutes I rather just the lady just
automated like would you like to press
it on my customer I'm like what do I say
speak to a representative speech oh
that's what I do I just keep pressing 0
0 yeah that used to be like such a thing
my remember when that first came out you
were like oh my god this is great I
don't got to deal with a person 1 3 and
now you're just like you know what the
heavy part is like you go through all
those numbers right and then go
rerouting you to a customer service
agent pocket [ __ ] that was 10 minutes
you could just add a zero zero zero zero
this is what I hate are you call and yes
I like please into your account number
boom please enter whether you answer all
this [ __ ] and then you get there the guy
goes what's your account number I get so
mad like why the [ __ ] did you your
system asked me for my account number
and they well sure the computer I was
like ah there let's go sir I'm just
confirming I mean I [ __ ] confirmed
with the keypad or any [ __ ]
night and it's not even that it says so
I just confirmed if you are going to get
angry at me they would I speak to my
manager
yeah they're really good oh man all this
[ __ ] talking about I know warranty get
off my lawn
I hear people walking along
[Music]
[Music]